one of the alters she was just so
she wanted to hurt herself and us
and
she would
try and burn me she would try and jump
off a bridge
uh all this sort of stuff um that
happened right up until i was diagnosed
my friends had to
restrain me every time we came up to
this footbridge because she would fight
them
run and try and leap off of it every
single time
[Music]
so can you explain what did is
so did stands for dissociative identity
disorder and it means that the
identity or personality as a whole has
been fragmented so
my
confidence side or whatever say has been
separated from me and i don't remember
that
and she's her own personality they
all collectively make my body which we
call a system
so each member of the system has to work
together to make the machine work
perfectly like [ __ ] in a system
um
and alters make up the single members of
each system the only
idea that i had about what this was was
split personality i'd heard that from
jekyll and hyde
um
just a movie i'd seen as a kid and
this doctor with this evil side that one
is so nice and innocent the other one is
a murderer and it's gonna kill you and
that's what i was convinced that i had
this this evil side of me because she
was so mean to my friends she was she
would hurt my friends you'd try and hurt
me
when did you first realize that there
was a difference between you and other
kids
um
in my teenage years
i noticed
that i was losing a lot of time and
that
i just couldn't remember what was
happening in classes and but then i had
all these people my friends coming up to
me and saying that i'd said this to them
i was i'd called them this name i'd been
really horrible to them or i'd stolen
something or i'd hit them or something
you know and i had no memory of it
whatsoever and
i just refused to believe that that was
true i just refused to believe that i
was doing these things to them but then
they would film it or they would
like
people other people that i would trust
like teachers would tell me yeah you
said that or yeah that happened and
that's when i started to realize that
something was going on that i couldn't
remember or even know what was happening
what was your first memory of having
alters
i was definitely a loner as a kid
i had a lot of imaginary friends that
looking back at it now are probably
alters they were real to me as a child
and even my family would say that i
looked like i was like talking to a
ghost or something because i just could
see them i could hear them they were so
vivid as a child that i just spent all
my time in my head
playing with these imaginary friends
they
would they started to turn around and
tell me that
this whoever was speaking out of me when
i was blacking out
um had a name had an age had personality
had feelings and thoughts and opinions
and
i thought i was just blacking out and
that
i was either like falling asleep like
narcolepsy or something or that i just
didn't remember it but the fact that
people were telling me that i was
doing things
i just yeah i just couldn't believe it
would you mind taking us through how
many alters you have i've seen that
you've talked before about having a main
eight is it yes there's a roughly yeah
about eight to ten of them that come out
there's me obviously beau the host um
i deal with roasted day-to-day life
if you meet
me you're probably gonna meet me
then there is texas as mentioned before
she was around from
as young as i can remember she believes
she's a vampire from the 1920s
we think so that she's
completely distant from my family that
she doesn't have to be related to them
or even connected to them she has her
own family back then
um
and she's very mean very stoic very
opinionated
um
there's tracy who's very confident she
would go drinking go out in very skimpy
clothes um kiss random people
just yeah i would just run off on a
night out and my friends would have to
find her um there's toast
don't know where the name comes from
he's a teenage boy he
likes video games likes to swear likes
to be boisterous
there's layla who is a six-year-old
she's forever six
refuses to be seen as a woman
um
she loves easter loves
childish things
i i'm not very like openly emotional
person i i might cry or be like that but
um
i won't get angry or um
start screaming or um
you know i don't very rarely get like
elated you know i'll just be kind of
content in myself whereas those
alters they
kind of take those emotions and release
them especially anger um
i don't get angry i kind of bottle my
emotions in which then kind of the
bubbles and bubbles and then
rosie will come out and just start
smashing stuff it's her job to get that
anger out so she just will punch things
and throw things in all sorts
can you tell us what switch between
alters looks like
so um
in my experience um from the outside it
can either look like i fully passed out
and dropped my head down to the ground
um
or it could look like nothing it can
just look like a blink i could be sat
here right now and then just blink and
you would be somebody else and you
wouldn't even know
um i think that's kind of the
same with a lot of systems is you can
either notice it
or you can't at all it's it's very
noticeable or not at all
um
in terms of what it feels like it feels
like falling asleep that's why i always
thought that i was passing out was
it
that
you know few minutes before you pass out
when you go to sleep you know you
you don't remember it you you start to
like go fuzzy
that weird feeling of your body like
going in and out of consciousness it
feels like that
but then that final moment when you
drift off instead of me dropping to the
floor of sleep somebody else would start
talking
what would trigger a switch um
so mainly it is either triggers
uh like so positive or negative triggers
that can cause a switch
which can be anything from a threat to
screaming to a car going past to
anything that triggers off my ptsd
response of i'm in danger can cause a
switch but also in the opposite sense of
um
something that is so vividly linked to
another altar like a smell or a flavor
or
something visual that can bring them
forward but it can
it can happen up to like a couple times
a day up to like couple times a week to
none for a month you know it can be
anything it just yeah depends on the
triggers that are around you if i spend
a whole month in my house and then
nothing's happening then
nothing will probably happen whereas if
i'm
out in london say
it might cause more because it's
so many more things or new triggers or
whatever sometimes i
can try and like fight it off like if
you're fighting to stay awake you know
you can keep your eyes open and you can
keep pushing your head back up if you're
dozing off but
eventually you might pass out you know
um
but it's exhausting like if i am ever
fighting it i'd get really really spaced
out i um
just get really really tired it's like
mental strain to try and keep yourself
consciously here
what causes did so
um most uh people believe that uh
like i don't wanna say anything
definitively but most people believe
that the id is
caused by uh
repeated childhood trauma which can be
anything from mass disasters um to a
murder in your family to childhood abuse
to anything as long as it's repeated
childhood trauma
do you know you've had trauma because
it's been described to you by somebody
um
yes and no like i have a
the weirdest memory that i know it
happened and i know what happened but i
don't remember how many times
or
how often or
what ages i just remember that it was
routine and that was the normal for me
as a child it's definitely scary like
knowing that i've had trauma and that
i don't remember a lot of my childhood
that it could have been anything
can you talk us through how your
teenagers were after leaving school yeah
so well
the majority of it happened in like
secondary school and that's when it all
kind of kicked off with
them just doing things talking to my
friends
one of the main issues with it was that
uh
one of the alters she was just so
she wanted to hurt herself and us
and
she would
try and burn me she would try and jump
off a bridge
uh all this sort of stuff um that
happened right up until i was diagnosed
um
she
yeah every time i would come to this
footbridge she would always desperately
try and claw herself off of it and to
the point where my friends had to
restrain me every time we came up to
this footbridge because she would fight
them
run and try and leap off of it every
single time
is that alter still present yeah so um
she's around she's been around the
longest i think
um
she's got like high delusions to think
that she's not part of my family she
yeah as a teenager used to ban me all
the time on i'd come to all the time
with my hand under a hot tap
and have to yank it away before it would
burn
was it the relief to be diagnosed
when i got the diagnosis i was i was
like oh my god this makes sense this is
this is incredible all these things that
have been happening to me for years i
know what they are now i'm not gonna
kill anybody you know it's nice having
somebody turn around and go you know no
you're not crazy this is a real thing
and it's happened because you've had a
bad life
and then
yeah but then you turn around and you go
oh god no but that means that i have had
a bad life and i have got this disorder
you know
somebody turns around and says you have
a very severe trauma-based disorder
then
you know that you've been through that
i think a lot of people especially on
social media nowadays
seem to think that it's lots of fun and
that it's
friends in your head and
that it's
uh
pick and choose cool alters you know
yeah they seem quirky and cool like a
vampire and a
trendy 19 year old or whatever but i
don't know anything about them i don't
know what's happening when they're out
i'm not
gaining any of the good parts of them
being forward per se
is there actually a cure or a medical
way of dealing with d.i.d
so
um
yeah you there's two main
ways of coping with the id so
the main that everybody knows is
integration or fusion which is
working through a lot of trauma working
through a lot of therapy
to
realize why you have these alters what
traumas they hold and then fusing them
into one big personality as a whole
final
person as what
this human was supposed to be
or
you can live functional multiplicity so
you can learn to work as a team learn to
communicate learn to share time
learn to
um
yeah work as a team to for whatever you
need to do at your job or be a parent or
whatever you know you learn
to do that as a whole group instead of
kicking the rest of them out and working
as one
the idea of switching and letting go and
letting them out is so scary to me
because of everything that's happened
but i don't know if i want to just get
rid of them all i think i probably do
eventually but i'm not at that stage yet
because i don't remember a lot of
systems if they switch they might
remember or they might
have a little bit of memory leak through
or at least know where they were or who
was out or something like that but
because mine is so
completely black out i need to build up
that communication first before i can
even think about getting rid of them if
i was to fuse it would probably be all
of them kind of fusing into me and i
would have all of their memories i'd
have all of their personalities so i'd
have
toast boisterousness or trace confidence
or
texas's mean edge you know that would
all be in me
um as one human
what advice would you give somebody else
thinking i think that's me
um
to not be scared i guess that was one of
the things that really affected me was
that i was just terrified of it um
to get as much support as you can
to
get as much information down as you can
i think i'm quite blessed in the fact
that mine will sit and record a video
which is very
easy to get the information across um
whereas it might not be that easy for
other people
what does the future look like for you
um
i'm hoping to go to uni um
hope to be a parent eventually
um
yeah
i
i worried before that this might be a
problem you know if i had an evil side
would they try and murder my baby but
i've seen now that
it's not the case at all that people
with did can be incredible parents um
and
what like loving parents as a team
and that
it's not going to be something that
stops me from
going to uni or
becoming a parent
[Music]
a lot of people who have tourette's tend
to report that they have fewer ticks or
none during sex but the thing about that
is that's because it engages your focus
so that only applies to good sex um
which is really [ __ ] brutal because
i've never hurt a guy's ego more than
simply go
during an intimate moment